so Steven Yun is out as Century for
Marvel studios's upcoming movie The
Thunderbolts it has been confirmed that
he had a scheduling conflict which is
why he can no longer play centry in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe however it
looks like Marvel has wasted no time
whatsoever and could have already cast a
new person to play Century in the MCU
which makes perfect sense because we're
in 2024 already and the movie has been
delayed from 2024 to 2025 July 25th to
be exact filming is going to have to
happen soon and Sentry is supposed to
play a pretty big role a really big role
I've seen some people ask on Twitter and
then the comments well how big of a role
was centry going to play does Steven Yun
no longer playing centry really affect
the movie that much well based off of
what we've heard about the movie and
cry's involvement from the Insiders yes
centry is supposed to be the main
antagonist of the film however I should
clarify that he is supposed to be the
main physical antagonist from what we've
heard there is going to be another
villain who we've already been
introduced to in the MCU we'll talk
about that in just a bit but first let's
talk about the actor who could be
playing Sentry in the MCU and if you
love Marvel and want to stay up to date
on the MCU be sure to subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
videos and for a chance to win a PS5 and
Xbox series X some Marvel Legends items
or some DC items all you got to do is
subscribe and leave a comment down below
we pick one winner at the end of each
month for our giveaway so according to
Daniel rpk a very well-known Insider in
the industry Marvel Studios has offered
the role of century to an actor on his
Twitter he tweeted in collaboration with
rdcu leaks I can report Austin Abrams
from Euphoria has the current offer for
Century in the Thunderbolts now if you
know who he is let me know your thoughts
about this in the comments down below I
know a lot of people out there have
watched Euphoria because of Zinda that
little Spider-Man and Tom Holland
connection I haven't personally watched
Euphoria and I don't really know to too
much about Austin Abrams but just by
looking him up real quick on Google
looking at what he's been in I'm sure he
has the potential to be a good Century
in the MCU however he's going to have to
buff up I mean century is the MCU
Superman he's pretty much always
insanely big in the comics however
Marvel has recently revealed that there
is kind of a new century in Marvel
Comics it's really interesting but
basically there are going to be three
different centuries there's going to be
one called far OD another called
mallerie and then one more who honestly
does really resemble Austin Abrams whose
name is Ryan and Jason louu the writer
for this series gave us some plot
details he stated this entire series is
a mystery where we follow Jessica Jones
and Misty Knight as they figure out
these catastrophic accidents caused by
random strangers with centuries Powers
you're going to witness a bunch of
origin stories like mallerie Gibbs a
writer for Frontline news who lives with
cable py farhod Anand who is a mutant
keeping a low profile as a door dish
bicycle Courier and Ryan topper a
teenage Fanboy who gets to live his
dream of becoming a superhero and there
are a few more further into the story
but the real question is how are they
all connected to Robert Reynolds so
right away I just got to say that if
they are introducing Century in the MCU
which of course they are it's confirmed
he is 100% coming in the Thunderbolts
then it has to be Robert Reynolds it has
to be the true origin story of century
not some kids who randomly get his
powers we need the origin story of
Robert Reynolds in the MCU the first
century a drug addict who gains the
power of a million exploding sons and
here's the good news I truly do believe
it is going to be Robert Reynolds
because his origin story kind of lines
up with what they're planning to do with
his character in the MCU in the
Thunderbolts film and of course it has
to do with the super super soldier serum
and also the real main villain of the
film the person who created centry more
on this and just a bit but first big
thank you to fume for sponsoring this
video fume is a GameChanger for a lot of
people in turning bad habits into good
habits a lot of people struggle with
these bad habits but fume looks at these
in a different way not everything in the
habit is wrong so instead of a drastic
uncomfortable change why not just remove
the bad from your habit and that's
exactly what fume does they're
Innovative and they're award-winning and
they're a flavored air device that's all
it is it's flavored air so it has none
of the bad things and the bad habit in
it instead of vapor it uses flavored Air
instead of electronics fume is
completely natural and instead of
harmful chemicals fume uses delicious
flavors I had actually heard really
great things about fume from my friends
who were struggling with some bad habits
they actually red about it and how it
helped them which is why I agreed to
partner with them and they sent me some
samples and they honestly are super
refreshing and taste very flavorful and
good and it comes in beautiful real wood
and it's honestly really fun to just sit
there and kind of fidget with if you're
someone who likes to fidget like I do
and I know stopping is something we all
put off because it's hard but with fume
it's easy and they have served over
150,000 customers and have thousands of
success stories and that could be you if
you pick up a journey pack today head
over to try fume
and use code Cosmic to save 10% off when
you get the journey pack today that's
trfu m.com and use code Cosmic to save
an additional 10% off your order today
so it looks like Captain America Brave
New World is going to touch on this a
bit as well with Thunderbolt Ross
becoming Red Hulk due to Super Soldier
serum and basically that's kind of how
it's going to be for Century however
instead of stumbling upon a lab and
ingested the golden Century serum the
formula pushed his molecules slightly
out of sync with reality so he developed
numerous abilities including a genius
intellect hulk-like super strength
faster than light speed and molecule
manipulating Powers all of these
abilities basically made him one of the
strongest beings in the universe and
here's where it all connects in the MCU
and will happen in the Thunderbolts in
Marvel Comics not too long after the
Super Soldier serum turned Steve Rogers
into Captain America the government made
a project Century this was a program
where a bunch of different scientific
Labs started to try and recreate or
improve the super soldier serum
basically they wanted to make the super
soldier serum stronger I'm sure this
sounds kind of familiar it kind of
sounds like what Thunderbolt Ross has
been trying to do since the very first
Hulk movie however Thunderbolt Ross is
not the villain that I am speaking of
the villain that I am speaking of that
is reportedly going to turn Robert
Reynolds into the century is Valentina
algra de Fontaine the woman who right
now in the MCU is recruiting all of the
Thunderbolts members this is why I said
before that century is supposed to be
the main physical antagonist of the film
while Valentina is going to be the true
antagonist and is going to actually be
the one behind Century now from what we
know all of the mental components of
century and the void are indeed going to
be a part of the Thunderbolts movie and
that is kind of where things go wrong
Valentina makes Century however she ends
up not being able to control him and the
Thunderbolts have to go up against him
he starts out as a member of the
Thunderbolts until things go wrong now
what's interesting is that before it was
kind of speculated that Valentina is
going to make centry in order to try and
get vibranium from wakanda however we
have since then learned that the
Thunderbolts are going to visit what is
being referred to as tyut Island because
apparently the celestial body which is
now dead and sitting there in the middle
of the ocean that'll finally be
addressed in Captain America America
Brave New World and the Thunderbolts
because apparently its body is made of
adamantium so apparently from what we've
heard from inside reports Valentina is
going to send her Thunderbolts team to
tyut Island to gather and bring back
adamantium and this makes a lot of sense
considering what we saw in wakanda
Forever we've seen that she really is
kind of a villain despite her job title
and what she actually does she is really
a villain and the issue here is we've
heard that other countries are going to
be fighting over tyut Island as well
however none of them are going to have
Sentry so they wouldn't really stand a
chance however the US government doesn't
really have Century either in the comics
before Robert Reynolds finds the golden
Century serum he's a drug addict with
psychiatric problems in fact that's
really the only reason he becomes centry
is because he breaks into the lab and
steals the serum so later on due to his
psychiatric problems he creates
something called the void and the void
is basically his evil alter ego and at
first Robert Reynold Century didn't know
that the void was really from him once
he realized that it was basically from
him he worked with Reed Richards and
Doctor Strange to have his memory erased
from everybody in the world which also
erased and got rid of the Void kind of
sounds like Spider-Man no way home in
fact if you simply replace Century with
Spider-Man at the end of Spider-Man no
way home and instead of all those
villains coming through it was just one
major big villain the void and Doctor
Strange erases the memory of cry from
everybody to stop the void from coming
into their universe and killing
everybody that's essentially what
happened and from what we've heard that
is still going to happen in the
Thunderbolts the void is still going to
be a part of the century and he's still
going to have a psychatric problems
which is why Valentina is not going to
be able to control him and why the
Thunderbolts are going to have to fight
him and we'll see what his powers are
going to be like in the MCU but if
there're anything what they're like in
the comics the Thunderbolts are going to
need some serious f Firepower because if
he is as strong as he is in the comics
if he does have the power of 1 million
exploding Suns the Thunderbolts really
don't stand a chance which is why we've
heard The Insider report stating that
the Thunderbolts are really going to be
going on somewhat of a suicide mission
in the movie and that's why they've kind
of been referred to as the MCU Suicide
Squad so the story for this movie sounds
super interesting and it looks like
century is going to be pretty much the
same as Robert Reynolds is in the comics
so the question is now if this report is
accurate and Austin Abrams has been
offered the role of century in the MCU
what do you think about it do you think
it's a good choice or not let us know
your thoughts in the comments down below
please don't forget to like the video
and subscribe to stay up to date on the
MCU you can find us on Instagram and
Twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching wolof woof